I can do things hey everybody it's
Charlie there's been a lot of
speculation about Wally West developing
new powers while he's on legends of
tomorrow obviously we have the flash
crossover with Jesse quick in Jay
Garrick coming up in a couple weeks - we
also got more information about even
more speedster crossovers happening on
legends of tomorrow later in the season
so there is a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter it just be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video is really gonna
be a flash bonanza across all the TV
shows but the really cool stuff first
what are the badass new abilities that
Wally West is gonna learn during his
life changing field trip to make as many
avatar jokes as possible we've seen him
demonstrate all the rudimentary
speedster capabilities like running fast
enough that you can run up buildings
super jumps across building to building
phasing through objects and people all
stuff that we saw right up to that first
episode obviously he's been meditating
so I'm assuming he hasn't learned any
new abilities since we last saw him
pending that starfish from outer space
the Storrow encounter is a bit of a
question mark right now because to take
down star oh the justice team and then
separately the Teen Titans had to team
up to do that so until they give us more
information let's just assume he did not
learn any special new abilities during
that encounter although that's what they
use those types of things for there's a
pretty standard list of abilities that
Barry has demonstrated and can do at the
drop of a hat like he doesn't even have
to think about this stuff anymore
throwing lightning while he could
totally become a lightning bender to
make another avatar reference I don't
know why they don't do it more like
avatar like he actually throws a bolt of
lightning like Zeus which somehow seems
more ridiculous than doing it the avatar
way and using the arc of your body to
just shoot lightning out of your
fingertips maybe they thought that
looked too much like Star Wars instant
take off which is when a speedster goes
from a dead standstill to SuperSpeed
without having to ramp up like when
Barry goes back in time he usually has
to do a couple loops of the particle
accelerator before he can get there we
almost got there during season 3 but
neither Barry nor Wally has gotten
particularly good at entering and
leaving the Speed Force at will so
there's one using the Speed Force to
travel back in time which is another big
thing but it's a whole other skill set
to
enter the speedforce and stay there
because while you're in there you're
basically existing is pure energy they
do have the ability to become pure
energy but it gets really complicated it
gives them a measure of immortality but
there are ways to kill speedsters like
just ask reverse-flash usually that
involves time loops though it's much
harder to kill something that exists as
pure energy the other big one that
people keep asking about is Wally
achieving ultimate speed like where he
can actually run across the universe in
an instant that's something that's like
way beyond normal flash speed and I
don't know if the TV shows ever going to
address it I think that Barry is gonna
unlock a couple more SuperSpeed
abilities when he's fighting the thinker
this season but because they do try to
be as comic book accurate as possible
relative to people's powers I think
there's a good chance we see Wally in
the next couple of seasons if it doesn't
happen on legends achieve a top speed
that's greater than that of Barry's
something's so unimaginably best that it
seems like he's existing in multiple
states at the same time like Barry
phased himself to turn invisible that's
probably another big ability that Wally
could learn literally vibrating your
molecules so fast that the human eye
can't detect you so technically not
invisible
just moving faster than the cameras that
are people's eyes for those of you
asking too about the cameras at the
prison - there is special anti speedster
technology that helps them detect
something that's moving that fast so
it's not like a regular camera that you
could buy on Amazon the detected Barry
you decide to assume that there are some
anti speedster measures that people have
started building since the flash debuted
a couple years ago zari has the wind
totem creating windmills is also one of
the Flash's abilities and then entering
flash time is the new one technically
it's not new but it's kind of a new
ability that they'll be doing in flash
episode 15 which is also we get to some
flash crossover so like I said there's
gonna be more speedster crossover in
addition to what we've already talked
about they confirm Jesse quick is
actually going to guest star during
legends episode 15 the title of that is
necromancing the stone Constantine is
also coming back for that so it sounds
like they might be invoking the spirit
realm it'll be interesting to see how
they invoke the jesse quick character
because there are a lot of people that
are wondering if the flash time episode
is going to invoke that twist from young
dis Wally West where he sort of
disappears and it seems like he dies and
you don't know what happened to him I
may not be as fast as you two but I can
add my fair share of kinetic energy the
thing about that on the TV show is that
speedsters being trapped inside the
Speed Force was a really big running
plot point for season three and I don't
know that they would rush to recycle
that so something happens with Jessie
quick that causes her to show up during
the legends episode whether it's
physically or whether she gets trapped
in the Speed Force and Wally sees her
while he's in there or the really WTF
twist that she could possibly die and
they're pushing into the realm of death
and that's how he sees her we start to
get into a lot of speculation when it
comes to stuff like that so I wouldn't
take too many guesses before we get more
information but Jessie quick will be in
flash episode 15 the week after that
she'll be in legends episode 15 and then
those are the only two episodes that we
know about her guest starring in during
the season if you saw the pictures that
the actors were posting from behind the
scenes with them in the cowboy hats on
that set looking like a Jonah Hex
episode that's actually the finale they
filmed that last week so largely legends
has wrapped up its business so do not be
surprised if in a couple weeks you see
Wally West show up on the set of the
flash TV show because I do think that
he'll go back for the last couple of
episodes of that if not the final
episode the real simplest power that
Wally will probably learn about is more
of the intricacies of time travel
so speedster time travel is a little bit
different from legends time travel they
use a more scientific approach like you
could make whatever Doctor Who explainer
you want to they call it the time matrix
they use Gideon that advanced computer
as sort of a hyperspace Drive to
calculate their route through space-time
the way the reverse-flash described time
travel to Barry during season one was
more of an egocentric approach like
specific to Barry's own timeline he
traveled back along it or he used it to
navigate because like reverse-flash can
travel two points in history before he
existed so it's not like you're bound to
your own timeline you really enter the
Speed Force once you hit a certain
velocity and then your only way of
navigating is just focusing on a
specific moment in space-time
so you're really relying on your own
ability to pinpoint what it is you're
looking for which explains why there are
so many problems with speedster time
travel like that younger version of the
reverse-flash during season two who was
looking for Barry Allen didn't know when
during the 20th century Barry was alive
so he just had to guess they actually
sewed up some of that logic to on
Supergirl when the Legion of
super-heroes talked about a big
apocalypse that wiped out all data on
the earth which is why reverse-flash
would not have had the data for when
Barry was alive exactly so let me know
in the comments what new speedster
ability do you want wallet to unlock
while he's on legends in how do you want
legends to use the Jessie quick
character if she's only going to be
around for that one episode I think the
real test of having multiple speedsters
running around crossing over to
different shows is actually going to be
Titans after season two because I don't
think we're gonna get a whole lot of
speedster stuff during Titan season one
just because they're introducing so many
new characters and they want to deal
with the core ones first and then that
even creates a lot of problems too
because they film in Toronto all the DC
TV shows film in Vancouver and I think
just in the name of sanity they want to
keep them separate for the time being
but I know there's tons of questions
about what's going on with the future
seasons of the show how they gonna use
Wally Jessie quick
what's going on with Titans there's like
a billion things happening right now so
there are any specific videos or really
big questions you guys want me to do as
videos just let me know in the comments
below
congratulations to that giveaway winner
from my last big video carros RL please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round on
this video I'll just announce a winner
when I post new DC there is some Titan
stuff coming up I meant to do a video
about so I'll try to get that out soon
really exciting stuff coming up click
here to rewatch that Brainiac trailer
and click here to watch my wally west
legends of tomorrow video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight